tattoo artist kat von d is in hot water
for potentially stealing someone's
photograph
to use it in a tattoo this has a lot of
people confused it seems like a tattoo
is a transformative work
and how is that like the actual
photograph well first of all photographs
can obviously be copyrighted
and the fact that it's transformative
isn't really the issue that actually
might hurt more than it helps
just because you've changed the medium
and taken it from a photograph and turn
it into a tattoo
doesn't mean you haven't committed
copyright infringement in fact that's
probably a derivative work imagine if
you
took a book like jurassic park and
turned it into the movie jurassic park
you've changed the medium but you're
still infringing on the copyright and
fair use probably doesn't apply because
you're not changing the purpose of the
original photograph it's still being
viewed for effectively entertainment so
kat von d could be in hot water and
liable for hundreds of thousands of
dollars under statutory damages
which is why she should really watch
this channel because if you don't i'll
see you
in court